[Music]
in life imitates art news oh I've been
saying this for years tape really aren't
imitate right oh that's Avenue [ __ ]
right there submitted by rolling balls
okay
yes okay a character look-alike from
Disney's Moana movie admits to swindle
Ling fan I heard about this too dad I
got to stop watching TV news with my mom
okay you can be involved what is this
like in knowing the whole thing yeah I
know it I'm just gonna assume what is it
don't zip it try your Dicky news
reporting okay so y'all want to hear
some juicy [ __ ] yeah having a date there
y'all know the TV uh I'm sorry the movie
momona yeah yes I do okay so you know
the main character played by the Roxbury
Maui I've never seen it but a big ol
do-right this would call him a
supporting care okay he's not the man
well I've never seen it the girl is the
main character name of the girl I said I
just said all right let's go one
shoulder let's do this anyway so you
know how parents they hire like those
look-alikes yeah kid party so there's
this dude that looks like what's that
what's that characters in Maui Maui yeah
he looks exactly like him Tiffany
picture name is Kyle he's 24 years old
Wow yup he looks just like him yeah it's
real hair real tattoos and everything
that's so cool he's missing some muscles
but yeah yeah you got the belly yeah and
I believe what was happening was these
parents were finding out that he does
these like what would you call it like
dressed up Paris's appear at the address
of appearances and he would get like a
deposit so that they would lock in the
date and then before she learned up
you'd be like oh you would never believe
this but like my mom is in the hospital
or Celyn are my aunt's like if there's
an emergency which this one his aunt has
a brain aneurysm and that he's been in
the hospital since 4:00 a.m. so he can't
make it
what's wrong with them what
the next thing you know he starts taking
pictures cuz he's at Disneyland and a
bunch of fans are like oh my god you
look just like him can I take a picture
so then he starts posting on his own
Instagram that he went and then he keeps
getting tagged by the people that see
him and everyone I think one of the moms
saw and was like what da [ __ ] this fool
when he cancels Ani does he at least
give you the refund
I don't think so oh [ __ ] and he's also
swindling people off of Disneyland
tickets cuz he says that he works there
oh I haven't seen that part what I did
I'm like I'll need the money tonight
though I work at Disneyland so they're
100 percent real but then he wouldn't
give him the past or like the ticket wow
what is shed how can you do that man
yeah that's not very Maui because now he
was all about the people who gave them
coconuts well yeah but then it's like
they're saying that life imitate
yeah life imitates art because Maui he
was the demigod that was banished to a
deserted island for stealing the heart
of people yeah but it was for vanity I
know I know
he stole it for vanity similar but
different yeah it wasn't for vanity it
was for love he wanted to be accepted by
the people that cast him out he loved so
he kept on giving the people what they
want and he gave them coconuts he
getting the land with the grass
everything I gotta watch this movie it's
a beautiful movie with the first time I
thought I got him a girl's voice is so
pretty like her singing
all I know is the rock sings in it he
raps to Mary oh yeah he raps like this
one part it was pretty dope that's
awesome yeah so this swindler he even
like admitted it he was just like yeah I
know I that was a lie I did go to
Disneyland
you know I see too obvious I'm gonna he
says I acknowledge what I did and I came
to this to let everyone know that I do
apologize for my action and that he
promises to do better and I here will
repay people because apparently like
three years ago he also had a similar
thing where he swindled like a friends
of his like where he borrowed friends he
borrowed money he's one of those you
would never pay back to the point where
I like the friend Ikey borrowed money
from had to call him out on Facebook and
then yeah this is this guy's not a very
we all met one person like this in our
lives
I bet they exist yeah yeah and it's
pretty sad because you know they
probably have really shitty families cuz
that's right [ __ ] this this is
[ __ ] stupid because he would have
made more money if he just did showed up
yeah he looks great from that party
other parents are gonna be like yeah all
he had to do is show up for work yeah
you could have done a bunch of these oh
it's great you don't have to buy a
costume you dumb just you literally it
literally cost nothing you literally
take off your normal clothes it is show
up at the kids place to work out really
yeah that's what a lazy [ __ ] back is
Perot
and Dom swindlers are so like immediate
gratification short-sighted that if you
just did it as a normal business they're
focusing so much on how to get around
the rules that they're doing more work
than if they just did the rules yeah I
already just been Maui and I would just
carry a little chicken around with me
yeah but he got really close to almost
upon me today eat it the stupid chatted
up talking about it we don't know what
you're talking about
I know I don't watch it it's so good and
anyone that hasn't seen it is missing
out I know I've seen it too I've
scrolled by I had to watch that film
it's all about Hawaii man yeah I saw on
the way to Hawaii I loved in Tahiti
it got me pumped up to you saw Coco
though right yeah God [ __ ] movie
theater
theater not yeah it's all caucus I think
it I don't think it's based on the why I
think it's based on the Polish yeah yeah
oh that's my favorite Island Maui that's
my favorite yeah I watched the whole
director Zoey lovers go travel for three
years they were going to like the
Polynesian islands they'd go to Fiji and
Tonga and all those places and they'd
like get input from the locals on the
movie and awesome they have stories Jake
show like versions of it so then take
for approval that's good it was really
cool smart of them and they the girl
that would be able to cast it for like a
Mawlana is why and go yeah you beat me
to the punch
[Laughter]
he's like there is a nineteen David yeah
it's in between the a you know that I I
just care about my evils that's you man
so this dude Kyle here he even got
Disney revoked his annual pass all that
is awesome come here no more and they
rescinded his job offer because I had
hundreds of thousands of dollars but he
settled for like a thousand I would love
to be a voice actor for a Disney film
will immortalize that would be amazing
problem is I crush a little too much and
your voice is not due to me actually I'm
a great voice actor oh how many jobs
have you had I have not had many jobs
however I will say this I can transform
my voice to whatever you like let me
hear one yeah let's hear me drive David
so let me hear do huh I behind a pitch
David stuff mouth I will say this though
you know that new animated spider-man
film yeah I
when if we're apart and let's say I got
called back three or four times came out
yeah but they were flirting with me I
miss so much they can use that [ __ ]
David took his side good luck choice
between you and somebody else and if
somebody else got it you up to somebody
else who knows what that somebody else
is oh [ __ ] on the brighter side you
won't be doing crack yeah do you
remember when jtt played The Lion King
played Simba jtt yeah Jonathan Taylor
Thomas oh my god plus they drew him
pretty cute Dean Steve I [ __ ] love
Gaston he was legit a rapist I didn't
like his character I just wanted a body
piece turned into a human I was like uh
yeah I was into bestiality in that movie
for sure I liked the teeth the piece was
so much better-looking than the grandma
you think that [ __ ] a rapist because
that girl was worried about luck a
little teenager and he was like thirty
years old I don't know I don't it's a
cartoon
pump your brakes you wanted to [ __ ] a
car to pump your brakes
max from goofy movie I was all up in him
oh my god Oh will you get the [ __ ] out
of here right now
Jessica Rabbit though and she looks
legit looks like you wanted to [ __ ] a
rapist and a beast I don't know what
you're talking about
you wanted to [ __ ] a dog okay and also I
like basil from Mouse Detective not that
anyone gets that reference because that
movie didn't really make it but he was a
mouse
he was a detective Mouse okay oh boy he
was smartest [ __ ] and I was like I could
have an intelligent conversation with
him oh my god don't you feel so bad
because I want to [ __ ] cartoons like
right now
isn't that what hentai is all about
that's awesome
[Music]